Thank you so much for coming.
I know we are on day 4 of Reinvent.
It's been an incredible week,
lots of new announcements, and so we really
appreciate you taking the time
to be here.
Um, I'm Christine Henley.
I lead our worldwide partner
programs for Channel and go
to Market with AWS,
and my friend Mike Eastman had
a personal conflict and so we're really
fortunate that he was able to call in a huge
favor and get us Rayhan Shaw
here today.
So Rayhan, if you wanna introduce yourself. Hi, I'm
Rehan Sham, the partner sales leader in the US responsible
for, uh, acquiring new customers with partners,
and I'm excited to be here.
All right, so much.
So we're here today to talk about accelerating new
customer engagement and revenue growth.
So just a quick show of hands, how many
folks here are from an ISV
partner?
Thank you. And how many from an SI or
consulting
and any distributors in the room?
Excellent. OK, well thank you all for making the
time really excited and we'll take some
questions at the end of the side here, so
keep those questions for us.
So what do we cover today? We're gonna talk about what
going to market at scale means
and why should you do it with AWS.
We'll talk a little bit about what is a partner
business practice and how to build one,
and we'll talk about that partner profitability
framework of build, market, sell and
grow and close with a few next
steps for you.
I'll pass it to Rajan to talk a little bit more about
going to market at scale.
Alright, thank you. So the
opportunity is vast, it's not limited, it's
huge,
you know, if you think about
the industry, if you think about
where the industry is going, the trends, what
are we looking at right now,
uh, just at the moment, and this is just
now,
the, it's the AWS
partner network has grown to 1400
partners across the 200.
Some countries and territories, right, so think of that
as an opportunity for you as a partner, you as a customer
to work with each other and create
solutions,
um, so that opportunity continues to expand
and why scale? Why not just work with
the larger organizations where the deal size is
a little bit larger, right?
It's because 98%
of the organizations are SMBs,
either small or medium.
So that's the opportunity right in front of you, right? And
this 98%, when you think of the small medium
organizations, 90% of them
are going to consider
some G AI solution in the next 3
years. So therein lies an opportunity for
all of us within the small medium
and that leading with some G AI focus.
And as we go further,
um. We're
predicting that 2026,
50% of the marketplace transactions
will be through a channel partner,
something key to note and understand.
All right, so let's swap over now. Let's talk a little bit about
the customer trends, what's happening from a customer
perspective.
So the big ones, right?
Um, first one is the industry
focus
continues to be an area of trend,
and then focusing on customer outcomes, customer
business outcomes.
Uh, Zeno, who's one of our partners, predicted that
75% of the enterprise buyers,
uh, will buy based on your deep vertical
knowledge and expertise. So it's
important to hone in your industry expertise.
The continued focus, I mean
you guys heard girls in the last 34
days, G AI, AI all
over constantly, right?
Um, and that seems to be not just the trend,
it's reality. So 81% of SMBs
and mid-market firms
are gonna invest
something in AI
according to Tech Isle in the coming
year. So that's right there, a huge opportunity in front
of you building a go to market very specific
to AI. And then lastly,
also very important is the focus on
multi-cloud, right?
Multi-cloud was a focus not just for enterprises,
it's now expanded even small medium sized
businesses are considering multi-cloud
solutions for different use cases,
so it's good for you to be
front and center in front of it and building your business
around it. So
now I'll talk a little bit about some recent
um customer use cases
where we've seen some outcomes be created
and for you to consider as a partner.
The first one is in Northern Island Loch
Nee has been building
a toxic algae bloom, um, battling
actually I should say
that was threatening drinking water
and 40% of the water in that region.
So the Department of Agriculture and Environment
partnered up
with private sector for a solution, and this
is where AWS stepped in with its partners.
So partners build Ingram
Micro, LG Sonic,
and Whole Food, um, Whole school
software joined forces to create a
Lochne AI powered predictive analytics
solution, and this solution then helped
curated
the right outcome for the customer and how to clean up this
water and have a solution.
That's really solved for
the overall environment, so a big one for
us, right?
The second one is an example, um,
JDS, Woodmark Consulting firm,
um, and, and basically they worked.
This is about a global maritime logistics
organization. The industry backbone here is really
international trade,
which is really dominated by a few large
organizations leaving small businesses at a disadvantage.
But when it comes to real-time tracking.
Or accurate, um,
arrival predictions,
JDS and Woodmark Consulting teamed
up to change that,
leveraging the SMB
competency,
GAI rapid funding,
MAP, and some of the programs that we have.
JDS was able to help the customer,
and they implemented a logistics intelligence
platform that leveled the playing field for
all businesses,
not just large organizations, also for SMB.
So a big one for us and big one for you as well,
right? Finally, in the healthcare
industry. When I think of quality care,
um, and it's becoming harder and harder now with
half the organizations of healthcare in the US
alone planning to switch careers due to burnout,
right? So Care.com recognized this crisis
and partnered up with Cloudhesive
and Guidehouse
to transform how
care providers and patients connect.
So this led to Cloudhesive's Amazon
Connect capabilities and integrating a solution
with Cloud Connect,
or Amazon's Connect I should say.
With Epic EHR systems
that's creating a HIPAA compliance solution, an AI
driven contact center,
um, that created an outcome in this situation
for Care.com to continue serving more than
45 million families,
so fast and furious, but in the healthcare
creating an outcome.
And as I continue building on this,
Christi, I go to you now. OK, thank you.
Excellent, so fantastic stories
and what I love about Rajan Shared is that it's
not just impacting the community,
but it really shows the power of when partners
leverage AWS programs to
help small organizations and the
only way to really do that is to build intentionally
and consider how you're setting yourself up
to go to market at scale.
So we have a framework for thinking about this with an
AWS which we call the partner profitability
framework.
We're gonna talk here today a little bit about the
build stage where you're creating capabilities
and solutions that solve real customer
problems
market where you generate demand and
identify that customer fit for the
solutions that you have,
sell and convert those customers into
real opportunities and engagements, and
then grow. How do you help those customers succeed
and expand over time and
find more customers that can benefit from a similar
solution. When
we think about those phases, there's one
other factor that comes into play.
When you're going to market together with AWS
we really see a partner maturity
journey of how you interact
and integrate with us and our programs.
The first phase of that journey we're calling
the opportunity phase. That's
where you have a solution and you've identified
that customer market fit,
but you're really working with AWS and our sales
teams on an opportunity by opportunity
basis which works really well,
but it can be very resource
intensive. It's reactive. You're building
relationships with sellers on each deal.
You're building relationships with customers on each
deal and pitching the value of your products
over and over again.
In this second phase we switch towards
intentionality. That's where you
start to really make deliberate decisions about
focus, which industries, which
customer segments, which teams
within AWS do you build long-term
relationships with
so that you're creating repeatable motions
that will help you scale.
And finally that 3rd phase is a
business practice. When you really have
a practice with AWS,
that's when the magic happens. It means
you've built systematic repeatable
approaches, hopefully some AI
and automation inside
that practice.
You have clear metrics, dedicated
teams, and a long term customer
engagement flywheel,
and this makes each deal that you
do less and less resource intensive
and really helps you go to market at
scale with many customers on the
same solution.
We don't expect you to get to this 3rd phase
overnight or in
every solution that you offer. Intentionality
really is the key here,
but I'm really excited to talk a
little bit more about two partner programs we
have that really help you
build this business practice and embark
on that long term journey with us.
So just this week we launched the brand
new Partner Greenfield Program
or PGP because we love acronyms
um so I'm gonna talk a little bit more about
this program. It provides multi-year
investment to help you focus on new
customer acquisition and helping more
customers realize the value and benefits
of cloud.
We're also expanding our Small
Business acceleration initiative or
SBAI.
We debuted it here
at Reinvent last year and have seen incredible
results, engaging over 30,000
customers through this initiative this year
already. And so we're really looking
forward to expanding it globally next
year. OK, so how do these
two programs work?
They both provide multi-year
investments with the partner
along with support, enablement,
packaged go to market solutions,
packaged marketing materials, and
other great information from
AWS that includes latest market
research, customer trends that we're seeing,
engagements with. Sales leadership and marketing
leadership teams so you can ask questions and
understand how we're thinking about the space.
The difference in the programs is
that the partner Greenfield program supports
you in engaging customers in the
mid-market and large enterprise size
segments,
whereas a small business acceleration initiative
understands that to reach small customers.
Takes a different type of go to market
approach and so we really partner with
you on what that scale effort
looks like and actually the roles
within sales that you'll engage with
in these two motions are different roles,
compensation models, and the way that we
work with the partner and Rayhan's gonna
go into more depth on that later
as well.
So are you ready to
build a partner practice?
Let's talk about how to get ready for that
stage and how to think about whether you're there
yet. The first step is in the
build. Do you have a clearly defined scope
and target customer?
And again, where you wanna go deep with AWS
may not be all the places that you
can serve customers or can play
or do have targets, but rather really
thinking about what are. 32 to
3 areas to really go deep
and broad
together with AWS
and then next you have those well defined
solutions and capabilities.
Do you have a good training model for your team
and execution ability?
In the market and sell phase, we want
to think about whether you have a dedicated
team that has clear success
metrics aligned to those goals.
We have found that goaling is critical.
If your goals look similar to our goals and we're aligning
our teams collectively, we
really see that business take off.
So being intentional about who
and how you're staffing inside your own
organization and then which teams inside of the Amazon
organization. You're engaging with can make a
big difference.
And the second piece to this is, do you have
a scalable demand generation
practice?
And that can look like events,
but are they one to many? Do you have digital
marketing campaigns? Do you have
websites? Do you have a prepackaged
so that you use repeatedly?
So really thinking about how you've
made your demand generation less ad hoc
and more repeatable.
And this last phase in grow is
whether you have a robust customer
success function.
So do you have a managed service
or a partner led support offering
or other mechanisms where you
stay engaged in that customer
account and look for their success long
term and play that business advisory
role for your customers.
So let's go a little deeper
on each of these phases and talk about what AWS
offers for you to help build
out that capability.
We're gonna start in the build phase, which is really
that foundation for your success.
So we touched on this for us that that
build phase looks like having technical capabilities,
a really clearly identified
target customer, and developing
the right solutions.
Some of the most common questions that we get
is how do we maximize our AWS
program benefits
and what I would advise is to work backwards
from the solutions that you're looking to build
and the customers you're looking to reach and
then identify relevant AWS
programs that will help
stitch together and help you go to market in
that space.
So rather than building from an
AWS funding program
outwards, I would think more about
who you're trying to engage.
How you want to engage them and then
identify AWS programs that you
can stitch together to get the
support that you need
and that's why when you look across we have many
different AWSS partner programs sometimes you get feedback
that it's perhaps too many, but
the value in that is that they're building
blocks that you can use to stitch
together that go to market that really
suits your company and your target market the
best and partners who are very thoughtful
in how they do that
provide really positive feedback about
how these programs work together.
So just as one example, our ADS
Business Outcomes Accelerator or BO
program can help you identify
and match make between ISVs and
SIs that want to build a solution
in an industry,
and it will provide
credits and support, SA
support as well
for building out that solution, and then
market development funds for taking that
solution to market.
And if you're interested in serving small and
medium businesses, we have an SMB
competency that can also bring
you into that community.
So again, you're looking at how if you start from what
you're looking to build and work backwards,
you'll find often
there is an AWS partner program that can
support you.
I did want to highlight a little bit more on that
SMB competency because it is
such a valuable program for scale,
which is what we were talking about today.
Within that S&B competency we provide
three huge benefit areas. The
first is go to market support,
provide market research,
industry insight,
customer trends that we see in our own
data, and joint marketing
campaigns and other resources.
We also have an SMB solution
community so you can talk to us and
other partners about what to build,
what trends we're seeing. You can get again
technical advice from our teams,
um, and we also have prepackaged
starter kits that can take some of that
build work out of your solutions,
um, so really enjoy
talking to all of our partners in the solution community.
We also provide expertise validation so
you do get this badge that you can showcase to your customers.
You get priority in our own AWS
sales and marketing initiatives,
including like on our website for
SMB customers. We do local
events where we bring our SMB sales leadership
and our partners together and do networking
and different. Events,
um, and we feature you in our own marketing
campaigns. So overall we've seen
over the course of the last year and a half that
our partners in the S&B competency
grow their S&B business 35%
points more year over year
than similar partners who are not
yet in that S&B competency.
And that's why I really wanted to stress that
here with you today and see if that's something
that fits your business model to take advantage of.
We are really excited to lean in based on that
success and deliver more benefits in 2026,
so we're adding a go to market capability
assessment which would help you self assess
where you're at in that journey and especially in that
partner practice building that we talked about. So
really excited to debut that and then
you can build kind of a learning plan for yourself.
We're gonna offer more build workshops and
roundtables.
Um, we'll provide additional
market research and market development funding
for SMB competency partners as
well as a co-sell workshop,
and we're also adding an SMB
track at our partner equip local
events where again, as I mentioned, we'll bring local
SMB sellers in to meet with you.
We'll also have experts, technical and business,
um, come and present to you on our latest
information. OK,
so a few tools and resources I
wanted to highlight. There are many, but there's a few
that are really critical to this build stage I
wanted to make sure are on your radar.
The first is SkillBuilder. Um,
that's where you can see custom trainings. We
have all different great learning paths
for different role types that includes marketing
roles, selling roles,
um, as well as technical roles. So
if check out a SkillBuilder subscription. Um,
really excited. Just a couple weeks ago we launched new
managed services trainings into SkillBuilder
as well, um, so it's a great place
to see that all.
And we also have a partner analytics dashboard
where you can view the training certifications
of your team so you can keep track
of how your builders are growing and learning.
We also have the AWS marketplace and AI
agent marketplace where you can
find solutions that you can consume and
help you build your practice and your solutions
out. So maybe there's an ISV that has
built a component and you don't need to build from
scratch. You can leverage their solution
or an.
Built AI agent. In fact, this week we
announced 3 new agents
built by our professional services team,
one around migrations. I'm really excited about.
So take a look, and there's a lot of ways that can
really speed up your development process by leveraging
existing
materials.
OK, so some key action items.
First is think about applying for innovation sandbox
credits, especially if you're building a new solution.
I think this program sometimes gets overlooked.
So just a reminder to really
work backwards from what you're trying to do and
find the database programs that fit.
Um, Review, oops,
updated competency requirements.
Um, we also have industry competencies
if you're looking to double down on a particular
industry. Um, we've enhanced our AI
competency as well, so there's a
good suite of different competencies to pursue.
Be thoughtful,
but take a look at what these new competency
updates offer.
And you can schedule a solution architect
review with our team,
um, or if you're in the S&B competency, we can do a
workshop with you.
So take advantage of these great
resources.
All right, I'm gonna hand it to Rayhan to talk a little bit more about
the market. All right, so the next phase
market, which is one of my personal favorite ones,
um, so as you think of market,
same, I want you to first look at the bottom.
Christine just talked about it, but I'm gonna drive it home.
Level the playing field for yourself.
Make sure you are leaning into the basic
foundational programs and competencies
that we have in the certifications.
These certifications then unlock special funding
for you
that gives you a chance to provide that incentive
to the customer, to your sellers.
You kind of even out the playing field.
The two big ones that we talked about today is
SBAI
and PGP.
If you're not signed up, sign up,
sign up,
get leaned in, take advantage of these two
programs that are big at scale.
Let me talk about the middle one a little bit more
and zoom in.
So in the middle this is the partner
tools and resources,
um, so if you're looking at partner marketing central,
what that is,
what that means to you, that's a place where you can go
get co-branded marketing material
that AWS has already created for you.
You just remove.
Put your customer's logo, your logo,
go to market with it, right? That's money and
research that we've put in that you're taking advantage of as
a marketing resource fully available to you.
The marketing development funds,
this is how you build your go to market.
Depending on what segment you're going after and what your focus
is, how you're accelerating those opportunities for your customers,
or how you're incentivizing your sellers to lean in better,
critical to lean in and get to know this.
And then lastly, of course, you know, we talked about the marketing
tools in general,
but just you, you really being the pro and the
expert and having a designated winner
on the team who understands how
to lean in and what these tools are and when
to use these marketing tools at the appropriate
time. OK, so let
me highlight a partner, right?
Uh, innovative,
um, and in this case
this is an exemplary job
in the market phase where innovative
has a 3 step phase approach
that's allowed them to scale
their initial customer outreach
along with retention.
And a proven marketing flywheel.
First
they meet the customers where the customers at. They
do that by attending industry seminars
and popular events and local events
so they know where the customer is present and what the customer
is focusing on and what the trends are,
right? So they've really done a very nice job of knowing
that local customer and market that they're going
after.
The second is
after identifying the customer problem,
it's really the speed, how fast
they move
in solving that problem and
creating an outcome for that customer.
And doing it in a way where it's repeatable
and it's scalable
across a few 100,000 customers. In this
case they leveraged, built
a tool called, uh,
Dursol IQ that's what Darrasol IQ
that you're seeing on there, which is built on Amazon
Bedrock,
and it was developed
basically
for them to go leverage their
past wins and use customer use
cases.
And they use that to accelerate
how fast they get statement works out to customers.
So in this case we are talking about.
What used to take them 2 weeks,
they took it down to 2 hours,
so just that reduction of almost 90%
in sales cycle time
means faster revenue for you and your
organization, right? And faster outcomes for this customer
as well.
And then the third approach that they talk about is the 8
AWS competencies that they have,
which has helped them accelerate this.
So this is a good example
for you to figure out as you expand your go to market
and figure out how to lean in,
um, uh, you know, a partner Spotlight
who's made some sense out of this.
Call to action for this market face as you
think about
how you lean in. The first one is.
Evaluate what you already have as a marketing
program. And are you utilizing
all the resources that are available to you
from AWS
in the marketing
tools that are available to you that we talked about in the previous slide?
Second one is leverage partner central.
Make sure you know which
applicable funding program.
Applies to a specific opportunity that
improves your chances of actually helping
the customer and accelerating that opportunity
and creating an outcome for that customer as well.
That's super critical.
And then always just having a complete
eye over your
marketing plan and assess that what does that
look like,
right? Keep assessing that as you're iterating,
especially in the day of Gen AI as you're building out your
plans fast and furious, right?
Um, and then lastly,
it's that identify, build, and execute
a campaign,
right, to support a co-marketing
opportunity. So whatever campaign that you're running.
Make sure you have a framework you follow it it's
wrapped around with all the funding programs with all the
content that's already available to you and how do you make
that compelling enough for the customer to get you a better outreach.
So this is the next phase of it
which uh it's kind of where I sit I'm part of partner sales
so I get to live this on a daily basis so I can speak to
it a little bit more realistically.
Our cloud sales center.
Two perspectives.
One is it's obviously there for us to
create scale in our business,
but this is also the scale on for you as
well. If you do it right,
you partner up with Cloud Sales Center,
this helps you scale your business as well, and
Cloud Sales Center is a very significant
investment for us.
So if you look to the left, the two big pillars,
you know, it's the Greenfield customers that are
new to the cloud journey
with AWS.
We refer to them as Greenfield, or it's the
small businesses that are still growing with us.
Um, and in those pillars in the middle
you kind of see how we, how we break down the sales
segments enterprise, mid-size,
and small. Enterprise and, and mid
as you would expect, have an industry focus,
and within that we have three different types of roles
in the cloud sales center that you'll be
partnering with. The first one is the DemandGen
team. Straight up just very
simple like the way it says they're executing on a
demand gen plan, calling on customers,
setting up appointments, engaging the unengaged
customer. That's what their focus is.
The second one is actually the seller cloud
sales rep is an account manager. It's an
inside account manager
that you partner up with that you co-sell
with in the field talking to customers.
And then the third one is the SBI
initiative that we created last year.
Part of that was partner territory managers that sit
down with you and build a plan
at the territory level
that you two then co-own as the customer,
you're the lead, and then you got the partner territory manager
hand in hand working with you. How do we make that territory
successful at a holistic level?
So what's your lean in look like
when you work with the cloud sales Center?
Straightforward.
But I think it's important to understand these
three intersects are ways for you
to earn the trust of that cloud sales
center seller
and scale your business through them.
So that first one is
MAP, our, um, most
popular migration assistance acceleration
program, understanding what MP is, how
it's applicable
at the opportunity level and how you leverage
that for the customer
at that opportunity level.
And then how you intersect and partner up very
closely with CSC as you're
going through that phase.
The second one is
Just knowing all the, you know, uh, whether it's
Gen AI and you're leveraging rapid funding
or you're working with Gen AI Innovation Center and you have
access to some other funding for POC to get activated,
but how do you align that with your framework
to accelerate and scale as many
possible POCs, obviously rationalizing
the ones that make sense
that create outcomes for the customer,
but it's a way for you to build a profitable business
around POCs that then land in consumable
workloads.
And then lastly we talked about this a little
bit today, but.
Uh, partner greenfield program
new, we're super excited.
When's it going live?
It's live, live, yay.
Everyone can sign up. Everyone can sign up,
yep, so take advantage of that, please.
Um, so let's draw some parallels and some comparisons.
We talked about the Partner Greenfield
Program, PGP and SBIA.
And you can see them both up on screen, right?
Very similar,
uh, the core purpose is to help
you build a business that's profitable and
help you scale your business with us, right?
So in the two frameworks,
PGP is a fit for mid-enterprises
and large enterprise businesses that you sell
and co-sell with.
Um, and I, I'll use the word co-selling because it's truly
just that you co-selling whether it's with the field sales
or cloud sales center teams,
but that's what that is to the left pillar, and you can see
the intersect is at the cell
that, that bottom flywheel is where you'll
be working with
the AWS sellers whether in the field or in CL
or in CSC.
The second on to the right is SBIA.
It's very similar again for you to make the business profitable,
but as we talked about, this is where you take the lead. You
work with the partner territory manager and you're
aligned at that level, owning a sales territory,
you know, the planning of the territory itself,
the tools that you need, joint marketing,
and then just doing events together
to scale across a few customers. But ways
for you to make money,
two programs for you to lean into,
similar yet a little different,
and Christine and I will be here at the end to answer
questions for you if we've missed anything.
OK, so
Partner tools and resources that
I want to call out for you that I think are
super important. Nothing
happens if you don't use AC.
If you're not the pro at AC pipeline, it
does not exist for us. We don't see the
opportunity. You're not generating pipeline even though
you may have a pipeline,
but we don't have visibility into it.
So think of that as like
the holy grail. That's where the relationship starts.
That's where the go to market gets activated
must lean in and unlock that motion
super important.
The partner analytics dashboard I personally
like that's a way for you to look at your overall business,
figure out where you have some stalled opportunity, what's
the pipeline, what's coming in from AWS, what are
you sending back out,
what needs hygiene,
so it's a good place to look at daily and be very rigorous
and bring that operational excellence that you need to
be successful with us.
And then lastly,
um, AWS Marketplace.
We're leaning on you as a partner to help us
help with customers see the value in transacting
through marketplace, whether it's a green field
customer an engaged customer, small, medium,
large, become
that expert for AWS Marketplace,
be that champion that advocates for
transacting through marketplace at scale
with your customers across all industries
across all sizes.
All right, another spotlight.
So let's talk about predictive
um exemplifies selling excellence,
um, knowing they want to reach customers
with unique needs.
Predictive
partnered with University of Alaska's Small
Business Development Center to kick off the competition
pitch series.
The idea was to give local entrepreneurs the
opportunity. To modernize
their businesses through AI,
participants joined from commu communities across
Alaska
with ideas like better connect rural
communities, making the wilderness safer.
Um, the winner,
Arneto
is the region's first AI startup
that helps tribal communities find resources
and events
through a shared community calendar.
And this didn't just stop in Alaska, by the
way. The team created a repeatable model
that was then scaled and supported across
emerging businesses
while enabling them to adopt ADWS technologies.
Each winner in this case
receives 25 to 50K
um in AWS Pro Serve services
plus mentorship directly from Predictive.
So the team has been very successful,
um, through this series and has now expanded
nationwide embodying not only CSE
but also co-growth as a partner with
us. OK.
So let's talk about a little bit of
where in the sell phase
you should think about leaning in.
So the first thing is
as you decide where you lean in with your go to market.
Across CSC get yourself oriented.
Is it SBIA?
Is it PGP?
Is it the small business that I'm gonna work with our
mid or large enterprise?
Get acquainted with those teams, get aligned with those
teams, build relationship,
start your engines and
start co-selling,
and it all starts with Ace.
If Ace is not configured, not working,
it's not activated, so that I would say that should
be almost first but front center for
you to keep in mind.
And then align that of course with your business model
as well, right? So your target audience
who that you're going after,
what customer segment, what industry that aligns
with based on that you build your alignment
with CSC within that specific segment.
And then lastly just review partner central,
right, um,
meaning as you work on co-sale opportunities
you make sure that you're always leveraging the best
possible funding program that's out there
for you to accelerate that outcome
for the customer on that specific migration
opportunity you're working on
really important to understand that.
OK Thank
you.
So great best practices and I always love
hearing those partner stories because it really makes it
real that there are partners leveraging these
programs and
helps show where their success.
So I want to close with that growth phase.
Now that we talked about selling, how do we
make that repeatable and also remember
that your best way to sell is really
to engage with customers you've already worked
with. It's going to be a lower cost
to engage with them and also that's where we start to
see larger and larger deal sizes,
longer term engagements, more advanced
workloads.
So this is a really important phase of
working with AWS.
A Few key programs and
incentives that we'll highlight here
in the foundational program sense
there's two key ones you can be
an authorized reseller with AWS.
There's two ways to do that.
You can become a solution provider in your
own right, or I really encourage you
to consider working with a distributor partner
who can help you with the operational overhead
of reselling as well as help you
learn across that journey. Journey, learn new AWS
programs, introduce you to the right AWS
teams, and really support you in that growth,
um, and so that enables you to take on
the billing and the transaction for your customers
and certainly
starts that long term relationship. Another
great way to build that long term relationship is through a
managed services contract and so we have
a managed services provider program. I'm
gonna talk a little bit more
about there. That's what I would consider a foundation.
Then we have growth accelerators. This is
where competencies can help you
prove your expertise and also develop and stay on
top of the latest trends in different
industries, customer segments.
Um, if you are interested to add a
new service or new solution offering
to your portfolio, pursuing an additional
competency is a great learning path and
way for you to do that.
So it really helps you keep your team fresh
on what's the latest and how to bring. That back
to your install customer base.
We also have partner led support
which I'm gonna dive a little bit more into
another great way to stay involved in
that customer account
and we offer some really cool tools, especially
through our AWS Marketplace console
and vendor insights platform where
you can see a little bit more about what that next
best sale to your existing customer base
might be based on AWS predictions.
In the strategic benefits section as we spoke
about SBAI and PGP both offer
market research trends and
things like that that will help you stay involved with
those customer accounts.
So I'll talk
about what's new next year
um we did evolve our
channel partner and resell experience
super thrilled about some of the changes we're
making to help our partners
work with new customers for the first time
as well as incentives to grow
customer accounts and to grow your overall
portfolio. Portfolio on AWS,
um, so really thrilled about that we've
also simplified the
program because we know
that complexity is the enemy of speed so
we're really looking at how do we streamline,
make it easy and predictable for
you, and that way it enables
you to build packaged go to market offerings
to move faster with your customers.
We also launched a new benefit for
managed service providers through the MSP
program. So already we have
a badge that goes when you go through our
third party validation you receive it
showcases that you're a next gen MSP
in our eyes.
We provide incremental go to market
funding. As I mentioned, we launched
a new skill builder training to help you and your
teams.
We've streamlined that application
process and now we've actually
introduced a financial incentive
that's a percentage of the revenue under
your management new for 2026.
We're also building out an ROI
tool so for those of you who haven't
yet developed an MSP practice and you're
thinking about it, this tool can help you think
about what investments to make
and what that ROI could look like.
Overall we're seeing in our AWS data
that MSPs who are validated
through our program see 29%
longer customer retention
than similar partners who are not in our program,
so really consider leaning in here.
I did want to touch on partner led support
again. This is another one that I think gets overlooked
sometimes, but it's a great way to stay
involved in that customer account whether
it's a large enterprise or a small
business. They all need support with their AWS
offerings, and a partner led
model really helps you
stay close to that customer, but then also leverage
our AWS expertise
and um.
And do custom training and workshops with
us you can lean on our support teams for
escalation support. You also
get assigned an AWS technical account
manager.
Um, and you have access to our AWS
support diagnostic tools and
training,
so we see that partners who leverage partner-led
support on average see 2 times faster
customer growth.
I'm really excited about that program. We've also
streamlined the partner-led support offerings,
um, to make them simpler and more predictable
for 2026.
OK, so true to form, a couple key
tools and resources that we wanted
to touch on
partner matching engine.
So as you get those competencies and
build out your expertise
internally at AWS we've launched
this AI powered matching engine
that uses your competencies and
your past work with AWS
to match make you to customers and
surface your profile to our AWS
sellers.
So a great way to get surfaced more to
our sales teams is to record your
deals in Ace as Rahan mentioned
and also to build out your expertise
with those competencies with things like the MSP
program that will really help highlight
your capabilities with us.
SkillBuilder comes into play here as well
because you need to be always developing that next
set of skills. So
coming back around, this is a great place
to go back to learn more.
And within that AceC pipeline manager
we have opportunity reporting
that can help showcase to you how you're
showing up in the partner matching engine, so
where are you're being most recommended and not
as much recommended, um, it can help
show you your strengths by
industry, by customer segment, by AWS
definition. Right, because I know that everyone
here has a different definition of what SMB
looks like and so if you wanna see
how you're perceived by our AWS
systems, all of that reporting is visible
to you through Partner Central, our
AC pipeline opportunity reporting
so really encourage you to leverage those tools.
So one more partner spotlight I'm thrilled to
share is a flagship partners Soft Choice.
They've really been on this Greenfield customer
acquisition journey with us,
and a couple of initiatives that they've implemented
and seen great success is that
they've leveraged the AWS customer
engagement incentive or CEI funding
to create a flywheel of customer
engagement on their own.
They gave new accounts a credit
towards their
soft Choice AWS professional services
which helped customers get started
quickly and accelerate their onboarding into the
platform and then newly leveraged our
POC and map programs to quickly
grow and move those customer workloads
onto AWS.
They also launched a cloud life cycle
Services plus program that
provides enterprise level managed services
down to even mid-market and small customers
at business support prices.
By expanding their managed services footprint,
this allowed Soft Choice to get to know their
customers more intimately and spend
more time with each of those accounts. Building
more automation into that platform means
that their internal team can spend their
time talking to the customer and understanding
what that next priority is and
stay on top of helping that customer grow.
So these risks of investing ahead
of customer growth have really paid off for
SoftChoice,
and that's contributed to their over 50%
annual growth rate with AWS.
So big congratulations and thanks for
being here today.
Or a few grow action items to leave
you with. So something to consider is scheduling a
QBR with AWS.
Again, a great way to do this is to get involved with one
of our programs.
Most competencies will offer you
access to that team for a QBR. Our
SPY and PGP programs certainly do, or
you can work with a PDM
to do so. But a, a regular business cadence
helps you stay aligned and understand
what are the learnings from the past quarter and how to
think about growth for future
quarters.
The second is going back to what I mentioned in the beginning around
growth metrics and KPIs. We really
deeply at AWS believe in goaling and KPIs
to say what's our North Star? What does good
look like? Where are we trying to get to, because
that helps everyone in our organization
problem solve along the way and stay
aligned with moving towards the vision.
And build a one team business plan.
Make sure you do have a documented AWS
growth plan that you can share
with all those stakeholders that you work with internally
and also use to guide yourself and your
practice.
This is also where, as I mentioned, you can start to
become intentional about how you're leverage.
Different funding programs together to
really contribute to a holistic business
growth and this is something that will help
you also get more attention
and and more alignment within AWS if we
understand where you're trying to grow
we can advise you better on how to work with
us to do that.
So closing, I want to come to a few
key next steps,
and I'll bring it to Reihan to take us home. All
right, so now that, thank
you Christine, I appreciate it, as you've seen
now on the partnership maturity journey
and you know the models that we talked about, right, the four
different steps which is the build, market,
sell, and growth.
And
the intentionality really matters.
I know some of us could be sitting at the opportunity
phase which is OK, you need a starting point
somewhere,
but I think it's just as important to move fast
from that to being intentional and building a business
practice
and taking a call to action, really important to
understand that and know that and get in front of it.
So as you think about that.
I'll let you read this on the screen for a minute and
reflect on it, but this is,
are you ready for this business practice,
right? So think of the four phases
in your build, market,
sell. And when you think of the
defined scope and customer target that
you're going after.
Do you have a clear customer identified
that you wanna go after
and build a go to market?
Have you mapped out solutions
for that very specific customer segment
that you're targeting, right? Important to do
so. And then as you think
about defined
solutions and capabilities in the build phase.
Have your solutions been validated by
AWS technical programs and
teams? Right,
um, and these dedicated teams.
With Success Matrix,
have you aligned your team structure
and your co-cell motion?
Do you have clear KPIs that
then build on that motion for you?
And as you think about the demand gen that
scales your business,
Have you mapped out a programmatic strategy
that scales?
Do you have a pipeline process
that goes across multiple tools and leverages
automation as well
so you do that at scale.
And then when you think of your customer success function,
right? um.
Do you have the customer life cycle
mapped out
and your approach
for that life cycle, what that looks like?
And have you
planned initial wins and long
term success when you think of this growth phase,
right, some questions for you to consider
and really as you're building your go to market, building your business
plan as you're executing,
have this front center sitting in front of you, right?
OK So what to do next
that's critical.
What's, uh,
should I go to you at this point?
Sure, sorry, I'm taking over your person.
That's all right. That's OK. We're on
the same page here.
Before you leave today, we have 3 action items for you.
First is think about that build market
sell grow pillars and choose one
program from each that you're gonna lean into.
What are you doing to do the next build?
How are you scaling your market?
How are you co-selling with AWS?
And how are you being intentional about
growth within your customer install base?
Second is. Assess where you think you
are in that partnership
maturity model.
Are you opportunistic? Are you intentional?
Or do you have a true long term focused
business practice with AWS?
And then the third is, please share this framework
with your team.
All this talk will be posted online in just a
couple of days,
um. We'll be off to the side for any questions you
wanna ask us as well, but
share the word and think about it internally. How
do you aligning within your company
to make the most out of your AWS
partnership? So we've given
you a blueprint and you have everything you need
to be successful. The big question
is
what will you build next?
Thank you so much for being here.
And we're going to stick around for questions.
We'll take questions as you have them, please.
Thank you.